Salutations distinguées
En rangeant quelques dossiers de la chaine,
je me suis aperçu que ça fait longtemps qu'on a pas parlé de tour de magie.
Et vous savez que la magie et le mentaliste sont extrêmement liés
et que je suis également magicien
Du moins, ça a été ma première activité profesionnelle
et un jour sur un close-up
un spectateur m'a fait un tour et m'a bluffé avec
Il m'a tenu au moins un quart d'heure à me le refaire avant que je comprenne
son tour est hyper malin.
La personne elle s’appelait Alex
Alex si tu regardes la chaîne.
Mets un commentaire en précisant l'endroit où tu vivais comme ça, ça me permettra de savoir que tu es le vrai  Alex
Et aujourd'hui je vais vous apprendre cette astuce
*Générique*
Histoire qu'il n'y ai pas d'embrouille
je vous précise quand même qu'après avoir fait des recherches
il s'avère que la technique. C'est une technique
populaire
Lui, il l'avait apprise dans un magazine genre Picsou magazine ou j'en sais rien
ce qu'il l'avait encore fait plus marrer quand il me voyait galérer à trouver comment il avait fait
Quand vous allez apprendre le secret, forcément ça va vous paraître simple à comprendre
je vais vous simuler le tour, comme si j'étais en train de vous le faire
pour que vous puissiez vous rendre compte à quel point c'est cool
Vous prenez un tout petit paquet de carte
vous le faites mélanger par votre spectateur
vous lui demandez de choisir une carte
de la regarder
de la remettre où il veut dans le jeu
et de mélanger le jeu également lui même
juste d'y penser
Vous récupérez le jeu, vous le regardez un petit peu
et vous êtes capable de sortir la carte qu'il avait choisi du jeu
C'est exactement comme ça que ça se passe
il y a pas d'autres embrouilles, il y a pas d'autres arnaques
Tout se passe grâce aux cartes que vous avez sélectionnés précieusement avant de faire le tour.
Ce ne sont pas des cartes prises au hasard
ce ne sont que des 7, des As sauf l'As de carreau
des 9 sauf le 9 de carreau
des 6, des 5 sauf le 5 de carreau et des 3.
Pourquoi ces cartes là?
|Imitatant N.Sarkozy] Je vais vous le dire
Parce qu'elles ont toutes une particularité, elles sont toutes asymétriques
Exemple de carte non asymétrique le 8 de coeur
que je le prenne comme ça ou comme ça, il est parfaitement identique
idem pour le valet de pique
Par contre, si on prends le 7 de pique, comme ça et comme ça
c'est pas la même chose
il a un sens
Alors 1ère étape, vous classez toutes les cartes asymétriques, d'un jeu de cartes,
dans un même sens.
Pour moi mon sens c'est de mettre tout à l'endroit
donc là on voit le cœur central il est à l'endroit, le trèfle central est à l'endroit
sur les cartes comme le 7 de carreau je le mets juste au plus haut possible
sur les cartes un peu particulière comme le 6 de pique
ça va être la même chose pour les 3 d'ailleurs
sur un 6 on en a 4 dans un sens et 2 dans un autre sens
donc ceux qui sont le plus nombreux je les mets dans le bon sens
vers le haut.
Vous voyez dans le 3 de pique c'est la même chose.
Donc vous mettez toutes les cartes dans le même sens, dans un sens précis
Vous confiez le jeu à votre spectateur et vous lui demandez de mélanger normalement
Ça s'appelle un mélange à la française.
Vous pouvez lui faire voir comme ça vous êtes sûr qu'il fait la même chose.
Vous dites: "Voilà je te passe le jeu, tu mélanges comme ça stp"
et il le mélange
Vous récupérez les cartes
vous faites un petit éventail comme ceci avec vos mains, vous lui en faites choisir une
Le spectateur va prendre une carte
le 5 de cœur en l’occurrence
pendant qu'il le prend dans sa main
vous allez refermer l'éventail mais pas comme ça, de la gauche vers la droite (de votre gauche vers votre droite)
c'est à dire votre index se met là
ça referme le paquet
et vous continuez le mouvement pour retourner le jeu, lui faire faire un demi tour
et ça c'est pendant que le spectateur regarde la carte mais de toute manière il n'y a rien à cacher
Vous refaites un petit éventail pour lui dire:  "vas y  remet la carte où tu veux dans le jeu"
le spectateur, donc, remet sa carte où il veut dans le jeu
et encore une fois vous lui dites de mélanger comme il a fait au départ.
et il mélange comme il a fait au départ
Et là vous allez faire semblant, avec vos pouvoirs de magicien, de capter quelques choses et te dire "OK j'ai ta carte !"
Je vois exactement quelle carte c'est
Déjà c'est une carte à dos bleu.
ça, j'en suis sûr et certain
Et vous lui dites "Je suis tellement sûr de connaitre ta carte, que je vais la sortir"
"tu vas voir que ça va être la bonne"
et à ce moment là vous prenez le jeu dans les mains
et sous prétexte de chercher la carte, en fait vous allez prendre connaissance de sa carte
vous passez les cartes en revue et elles sont toutes dans le même sens
alors comme on a fait un demi tour toute à l'heure, maintenant elles sont tout est vers le bas
Tout est vers le bas, vers le bas, vers le bas, vers le bas.
on a bien les 4 qui sont vers le bas
et le 5 de cœur est la seule dans le bon sens
toutes les autres sont également vers le bas.
Ça veut donc dire que la carte du spectateur c'est le 5 de cœur, donc vous la sortez du jeu
Vous lui dites  "Est ce que tu peux me dire quelle carte tu avais choisi"
il vous dit "5 de cœur"
et vous faites "BAM"
Et là, parfois les gens s'évanouissent
Surtout si, ils n'ont pas mangé depuis 48h en fait, sinon ils restent debout
Une fois les hurlements de la foule terminée vous remettez le 5 de cœur dans le jeu
dans le même sens que les autres et vous êtes prêt à refaire le tour
La seule chose sur laquelle il faut être toujours vigilant
c'est si le spectateur prends la carte comme ça, la mets devant lui
vérifiez qu'il ne soit pas en train de la tourner
en vrai ça n'arrive jamais, mais je vous le dis
quand même au cas où
puisque le but du jeu c'est que la carte ne soit pas remise dans le même sens que le paquet
donc si vous tournez le paquet et qu'il tourne sa carte, va falloir encore une fois tourner le paquet
mais je vous le dit vraiment pour information si un jour ça arrivait
Pareil, si jamais en mélangeant il fait tomber les cartes
Ça, ça m'est déjà arrivé par contre
pas de panique vous ramassez les cartes,
vous ramassez le paquet, vous remettez un peu dans le bon sens
sous prétexte de vérifier qu'il manque pas de carte
et vous dites "Tu sais quoi on va tout reprendre à zéro"
Voilà ça change un peu, ça faisait longtemps qu'on avait pas fait un tour de magie sur cette chaîne.
J'espère que ça vous a plu
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à nous le faire savoir en laissant un pouce en l'air
"A Nous le faire savoir". Genre il y a une équipe derrière tout ça.
Si ce genre de tour de cartomagie, vous plait n'hésitez pas également à m'envoyer un petit message en privé.
et je me ferai un plaisir de vous renvoyer vers des ouvrages spécialisés
qui sont fait par des éditeurs spécialisés dans la prestidigitation
Ce sont des livres un peu plus chers que la moyenne
ça demande du travail mais si vraiment vous voulez vous mettre à la cartomagie. C'est par là qu"il faudrait passer
Les livres et le travail
SI jamais vous êtes pas abonnés à cette chaîne
je sais que ça peut encore arriver
N'hésitez pas à cliquer ici. Et rendez vous demain à 17h
Tchao !